welcome back to the game so it stayed
here at e3 2016 joining tomorrow night
to talk about Rico is Joseph statins you
have the senior creative director of
Microsoft Studios you're also writing
the game is that right that's right they
let me out of my cage right this one so
that's been a lot of fun let's talk a
little bit about you know who's making
the games obviously it is a joint
venture between armature studios in
Austin but also we've got concept which
is una in a furnace ons studio over in
Japan how do those two studios work
together I mean the time difference
alone yeah one work in mwanza sleep yeah
absolutely reek or is this great
international project where we've got
people in Austin and you know over Japan
and other places around the world too so
it's been actually a lot of fun that's
what Microsoft publishing does really
well is bring together different teams
to create something really special i
think recourse a great example of that
what is enough innocence involvement in
the game so he he's been involved every
step of the way especially in the early
concept phase he has a real love for
memorable colorful characters and you
can see that in the in the you know
characters in the game so he brought all
of that strength and armature do many
things well but they're great at systems
and gameplay and technology and when you
put those two Studios together it's been
a really just great experience I got to
play the other day and go like along
with the character stuff it's it's very
immediate the influence in terms of game
design and mechanics that in a few days
seems to have whether it's intentional
or unintentional but like I came away
feeling like wow this is there's a lot
of megaman in this game the way it feels
the way the shooting works and the kind
of the way challenges you to think about
so much at the same time while you're
not in combat and stuff so absolutely
yeah it's definitely one of those games
that you look at and think oh that looks
easy that looks pretty simple lets you
know color matching but when you get
into it the mechanics are actually very
deep and you have a lot of options as a
player not just shooting which you will
but the way that you control your core
box when you send them in to interrupt
enemy attacks all those kinds of things
we like to talk about it as having a
classic feel like a classic Mega Man or
Metroid game but brought into the modern
era with a you know modern engine and
some progression mechanics that mean you
make it feel fresh yeah I think I think
one of your
developer said it like it's a game about
shoeing but not necessarily about
focused aiming yeah so about it's a lot
about movement and reacting to what's
around you and kind of like take
assessing threats and then figuring out
what you can do to best manage those
threats absolutely absolutely yeah and I
think Mark Puccini the game director
says that very well it's not about
aiming but it's a you know it's a
shooting game yeah and like from a basic
perspective like she's into making the
making a megaman connection again she
has her gun which he fires like a spread
shot yep and then you have a charge show
as well again like Mega Man and
absolutely that's about like doing
damage managing like your your the waves
of enemies are approaching but then you
have this almost ikaruga style mechanic
nakorn the color matching can you tell
us a bit about it yeah absolutely so you
can see here yellow is good against
yellow it's really at that level pretty
pretty simple but because you have
encounters with multiple color types of
enemies it does get really interesting
to manage the system so you're using
your d-pad to swap between different
ammo types you know all the colors and
then white which is sort of a neutral
color that's good for for lots of
different kinds of enemies we're still
playing around in the polish phase about
do we want the different weapon colors
to have slightly different effects fire
rates that kind of stuff so we continue
to tune it's been really fun to bring it
to e3 and have people actually play it
and give us some some feedback on that
right so the area i played was very like
you'd get one type of color but am i
right in thinking there's enemies that
change is there maybe i could have heard
about like shifting color phases and
that kind of stuff absolutely so there
are more challenging bosses bosses in
the game that don't start off they start
off as one color but they're able to
adjust your tax and permute their colors
so you might be fighting a boss that can
cycle through all the colors for this
section I played was what reminded me
most of Megaman you have yep giant enemy
that is kind of like he's my favorite
enemy right what his name was his name
well he needs a better name which I go
back to Redmond and figure something out
but we call the master spawner right now
yeah constantly spewing Aziz spawns
yang's so it's like just this classic
Mega Man style setup where it's just as
flowing boss that isn't directly
damaging you is to menacing and its
expiry enemies and the challenges in
kind of making sure that you don't fall
down a pit or get overwhelmed while also
making sure that you've got the
opportunity using your opportunity to
kind of like drop a bomb in there like
shooting with a blaster that's like one
of the moments where I was like this is
megaman yeah they're not calling it mega
man but it is absolutely he's called to
their two types of robots in the game
they're the core BOTS like the spider
and the dog and the gorilla and then
they're these things we call core bites
that can be very very small or very
large like that master spawner in each
of the core bites and there are many of
them in the game they each have the sort
of unique gameplay hook we're showing
off a couple of them now but when you
play the full game there are lots and
lots of different enemies that you can
that you can fight against it's really
fun yeah the way that we mix and match
them up that encounters could really
need so you mentioned the core bots and
these are also your companions right the
main characters jewel and she's kind of
like a scavenger type character almost a
little bit so Jules really simple story
is that she's a colonist sent to far
Eden to prepare it for many more humans
to arrive okay she goes to sleep for a
couple hundred years and expects pas
readin to be full of water and trees and
totally terraformed but of course when
she wakes up none of that has happened
all the robot helpers have gone crazy so
she's a colonist but also a technician
responsible for maintaining some of
these terraforming systems but she's
given this big new challenge that she
was never prepared for which is getting
far even back on track essentially
saving it and then with being one of the
core bots there so how do the core bots
kind of factor in we see him when we
first saw the trailer they were kind of
like this cool companion but they
actually they kind of melded into
gameplay way more than initiate than
initially expected right absolutely so
when you start the game as jewel you
have your companion that jewel was sent
to far eating with each human is paired
with a core bot and she was paired with
Mack the blue core in the dog and as you
go through the game she'll end up
meeting Seth the spider and Duncan the
big ape frame each of them you can see
here seth has this unique ability to
crawl around spider rails in the world
you might see some spider rails early in
the game before you get Seth and you'll
be able to later in the game backtrack
to those areas and access you know
places in the world that you couldn't
before so it has very much that metroid
ish yeah you'll that's the connection
told which are
because X Metroid Prime developers and
that kind of stuff absol so we can
expect that kind of like format where
you're unlocking new items going back
rediscovering areas within areas that
you may have already explored correct
them yeah do you sorry so what are the
cool wats all available from the very
start or is it just you know you collect
them as you go you unlock them as you go
yeah um from the chat we have a question
is obviously with the color switching
mechanic how have you changed that for
colorblind gamers you know that's a good
question and we do have accessibility
testing that we're doing right now and
that's the real good part about the
final polishing phases were able to
bring in lots of different players and
see how how they you know can play and
what we can do to make it more
accessible and I don't have the right
answer right now but that's the phase
that we're in right now with the game
right in terms of story that's the one
thing I wanted to discuss like the area
i played was quite light on story
obviously because it's in the middle a
challenge has all the mission has
already been set up so it's kind of
isolated but jewel and her role is to
kind of like colonize get prepared the
planet yeah what's the kind of threat
there she's facing is she facing a
friend is it just a game about just kind
of cleaning up right yeah oh and that'd
be fun that would be a game fortunately
it's it's a little more than that so
jewel came too far Eden with a group of
colonists but when she wakes up she's
the last human on the planet as far as
she knows all the core bots are most of
them at least have been corrupted by
some influence that she doesn't
understand some of the core bot scores
have actually been turned black into the
strange corrupted form so her first
problem is hey how do I actually get
some get some help on my side to tackle
some of these bigger problems which is
why she starts linking up with the other
core BOTS but the bigger problem is
clearly there's probably some big bad
guys responsible for doing bad things to
the core BOTS so she's fighting against
that part and also just changing the
world back to the way it was meant to be
so as you go through the overworld afar
eat in this desert place you will also
come across dungeons old facilities
building structures that were meant to
be the things that brought far Eden to
life those are the dungeons in our world
and jewel will go into those facilities
get them back online but the whole big
goal the big challenge is to rescue
far Eden from these terrible storms that
are plaguing it and run yes chef want so
so she she's walking around is she going
to be talking to like the core but sirs
there's gonna be some element of like
self-talk because obviously there's no
other human right is around so if
anybody's ever seen a lassie movie where
the boy will turn to lassie hugo's were
far from ya last see there's someone
down the well there's a little bit of
that in recore where she is conversing
with Mac and Seth who speak in this
didja mote language we call it but Jules
able to understand it so she's able to
have conversations with the core bots in
the world and we tell the story that way
would also some other ways that we're
telling the story that we're not
revealing today but suffice it to say
jewel does not just sort of walk around
talking to herself wondering what's
going on but each of the core BOTS has
their own personality and that shows
through in the way that she talks to
them and interacts with them no seems to
be built into that character design as
well right was that a lot of fun to kind
of combine the character design with the
the character that you were writing at
the same time absolutely so I think it's
pretty easy to make a charming dog
everybody knows what dogs do when
they're scared or injured but to make a
charming spider that was a really fun
challenge from a character design point
of view and Seth when you first meet him
with the yellow core is a very cowardly
spider so he's twitchy and nervous and
he scrunches up into a little cute ball
when he's afraid Duncan the big gruff
gorillas very stubborn and tough and so
getting those personalities into them
was a was a real a real treat and wear
uniforms on and armature and their
special magic together really came
together you've got a dog in there for
the dog people out there will there be a
cat for the cat people I'm a cat guy and
I'm frankly a bit sad i've not seen a
cat yet you know on her i have had lots
of questions about that and maybe i'm
biased cuz i'm a total dog guy cat
people are cool too how we know we know
sorry like to us we just undergo
standoffish though and little unkind of
hard to read sometimes like it yeah
that'll eyes well yeah yeah uh I suffice
it to say that we would love it if
recours a success and we can continue
the story beyond the first version and
there a ton of great other core bots
that we have designs for that we just
enough time to build for what you're
saying is cat DLC that's not a bad idea
so there's an area just beyond this bit
that I played that kind of really
highlighted what I loved about Rico and
it's an area where you're kind of in an
arena but the floor of the arena is
split up into three areas that are
catching fire one by one yes and at the
same time you're battling these waves of
different types of enemies that also
have different colors so it's really
about having so much laid on top of each
other and then just remembering how to
use each part to your advantage and the
best way to use your abilities and
movements and stuff exactly you know we
say I think for a lot of games that it's
deceptively simple it's easy to start
playing but it's really deep and
challenging the further you get into it
you know that really is true with recore
you look at it and think oh it's a color
matching game it's going to be pretty
straightforward but no like there are
rooms that are that are tough like real
real challenges and we've had people
come back through the line couple times
because they really really wanted to
beat the flame they got close but they
couldn't quite do it once you get
familiar with the controls it's this
awesome ballet of choices where you as a
player capsules weapon you have the
Corbett's you have all their special
abilities and the flame room when you
look at it first like oh my god how am I
gonna like get into flame room but once
you get into it and see a play it's it's
really satisfied yeah and that's not an
exaggeration because like I was telling
you earlier in my demo the person in
front of me was dying so much that I was
like I need to call someone and get
Kendall I need to have my goal here so I
can get out of it yeah but yeah it is
difficult and and there's also like in
my written preview of it was so kind of
liking elements of it to a bullet hell
shooter yeah because obviously like
megaman jewel has these thrusters on her
feet that she can use to give us some
like air control and dashing and at
times there's so many enemies that are
all firing these lasers at you that you
kind of like God identify the whole yeah
just like jump and use your thruster to
kind of get through this so you can get
a bit of like anything room and then you
can use that so like was that an
influence to like stuff like Ikaruga and
you know how so shoes yeah I don't know
if you notice this but there is really
no cover yeah if you're in the constant
motion correct so we like to say that
your movement is recover right for jewel
to evade the attacks like the expanding
fire rings or the you know laser line
that will stun you it's really all about
jumping dashing getting out of the way
so that movement
is you know super important not just for
the platforming traversal challenge but
actually to survive in in combat so
thank you so much for joining us I know
you kind of you guys are like in the
final polishing stages but give us a
quick reminder of the release date so
recore is coming out starting September
13th of this year for Xbox one and
Windows 10 and it's part of the xbox
play anywhere program it's actually the
first game coming out for that so buy it
on one platform play down the other vice
versa awesome that all works great thank
you so much you bet and for more
coverage from this year's e3 of course
make sure you stay tuned to gamespot.com
you're watching the game spot stage
brought to you by airheads